امين الله عادل وزاهد عادل زوجاني ينيويان
الحج هذا العام يخرجان الى السوق لاقتناء
كل ما يحتاجانه في رحله الحج من حقائب
وملابس الاحرام وغيرها وعند الوداع يجتمع
الاقرباء والاصدقاء في منزلهما ثم يذهبان
الى مجمع الحجاج في كابول لينتظر الرحيل
كنت انتظر هذه الفرصه وانا اشعر بالغ
السعاده لانني اذهب مع اسرتي
وسنقوم باداء الحج سويا في هذه السنه
فاسال الله ان يتقبل منا ومن جميع هؤلائك
حجهم ويجعله حجا مبرورا
هنا وفي هذا المجمع ينتظران مع غيرهما من
الحجاج الذين يتم حشدهم من المقاطعات
الافغانيه الاخرى ان رحله الحج المباركه
تبدا منذ الخروج من المنزل كما تقول
الحاجه زاهده ندير
انا مسروره ومحظوظه جدا بان اتاحت لي فرصه
السفر الى الحج فثواب حج بيت الله عظيم
والصلاه فيه تعادل الاف الصلوات في غيره
من هنا ومن مجمع الحجاج في كابول يتم نقل
الحجاج في هذه الحافلات الى المطار الدولي
بيكابول ليبداوا رحلتهم المباركه بعد
اجراءات في المطار عبر طائرات الكامير
الافغانيه الى الاراضي المقدسه عبد النادر
العربيه كابول لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات